The thing that's beautiful about Islam
is everything makes total sense. Because
now I think I wrote this earlier in a
couple days ago is that when the prophet
Muhammad
peace be upon peace be upon him came, he
cleared up all of the confusion
surrounding Jesus. Really? Without
actually without Islam, we really don't
know what Jesus said, what he
>> Without Islam? What he Yeah, because
Islam gives a complete life story
summary at least of the Really? life and
teachings of Jesus. All right, so where
so where does it say that Jesus taught?
Where does it say? That he taught? Yeah,
like where when he taught, where does it
say? Like does it give the place where
he taught?
Um well, Jesus was born in
Palestine. What city? What city was he
born in?
Um
so Jesus it doesn't actually give that
detail. You're right.
>> aware of in the Quran. What about where
he taught? Where did he begin his
ministry? Does it give that?
Um
so it doesn't in the Quran it doesn't
give those those details. Right. But you
just
What what about his uh the names of his
disciples? Does it give that? No. So you
see how you don't know anything about
Jesus from the Quran. Where do we find
Jesus making this statement?
Where do you find him making the
statement? What do you mean?
Because the Quran is quoting Jesus from
the 1st century. Where do we find Jesus
himself saying this? Like the direct
statement. Right here in the Quran. So
okay, so it's not until 600 years later
that we actually can know that Jesus
said this. Well, if you were there at
the same time that Jesus was alive, and
you were one of his followers, then you
would you'd have heard this.
Um even after he left, as long as people
were around to pass to pass on the
teachings of Jesus, you would have heard
this. Okay. But what is the proof that
he said this? The Quran is the is the
proof. All right, so the only proof that
we have that Jesus made this statement
comes 600 years after Jesus, correct? Um
I don't know if I want to say the only
proof because there was there was still
scriptures. Good. There we go.
Excellent. That's what I wanted you to
say. That's the answer. There was there
was still scriptures at that time. So do
we have any evidence of any scriptures
where we can find the statement? Yeah,
you have your Bible in front of you,
don't you? I do. So we can find where
Jesus makes this statement, I came
confirming the Torah, I'm a messenger of
Allah, and after me will come one named
Ahmed. We can find that statement in my
Bible? Not in those exact words. So
that's what I'm asking for, this
statement. Okay, let me let me try to
explain to you. Okay.
See, Muslims why why do Muslims,
especially those who were formerly
Christians for example, or other
religions, why do they accept Islam?
It's because they follow the principles
of the Bible, and by using those
principles, they they come to Islam. By
using the principles of the Bible, they
come to Islam? Yeah. Okay, where do we
find Jesus making this statement in the
Bible?
I'll well, like I said, you won't find
these exact same words in the Bible. So
there's no evidence of this statement
that preexists the Quran? Well, I was
getting to that. Okay.
>> Okay, so if you follow the principles of
the Bible,
the Bible teaches that there's one God,
correct? Yes. And the Bible also teaches
that this one God, he sends prophets and
messengers to people in order to teach
the people. Sure, where does Jesus make
this statement before the existence of
the Quran?
>> I'm getting to that. He doesn't
>> taking too long, my friend. I asked I
look, how how I like to how I like to do
things, man, I like to deal with things
directly. I don't like long-winded stuff
that doesn't matter, that has nothing to
do with what we're talking about. So can
you give me some substance on what I
asked?
>> So these the the exact wording of verse
number six in sura in in chapter 61 is
not you won't find it in those exact
same words in the Bible.
>> So I will not so I won't find this
statement anywhere except the Quran that
came 600 years later, is that correct?
>> Exactly how it's written here, no. Okay,
so remember that's what I asked. I asked
for the state this statement that I'm
seeing from the Quran cuz it quotes him.
It quotes him in for you know, you see
the quotations. Yeah, but Jesus son of
Mary said, and then we have this
quotation from Jesus. So you're saying,
admittedly, that this statement doesn't
exist before the Quran hops on the
scene, correct? Well, not that we have
in front of our our hands right now.
Okay. Cuz I I don't think even you don't
you don't believe that everything that
Jesus taught is contained within the New
Testament, do you? But we have what
Jesus taught. So But not everything. to
to answer your question directly, no, we
don't have everything that Jesus taught
and did because not everything was
necessary to put in the books. That's
what John says. If he were to put
everything that he taught and did, cuz
he did many things many more things,
then it would have been, you know, the
the books wouldn't be able to contain
all that information. So obviously
that's his, you know, that's his
statement.
>> about the most important one second. So
for yeah, the most important things we
have here. And so we have
Let me just let me finish. We have what
Jesus taught. We have what Jesus taught.
We have it in writing and existing
before the Quran hopped on the scene,
600 years before. And so if you're
saying, and you're acknowledging, okay,
you know what, no, we do not find this
statement. We do not find this statement
in anything that in any of the writings
from Jesus's teachings. Okay? Which is
good, I'm glad you acknowledged that cuz
I agree with you. And then I'll I'll
I'll bring down the question now. I'll
bring down the challenge. Do we have
anything resembling this statement from
Jesus about Ahmed coming? Does he
mention Ahmed at all before the Quran?
The question I want to I want to ask
again.
Are you saying that all of the the main
the most important teachings
all of them, everything that he said
that was important of the most important
of the greatest importance,
are you saying that all of those things
are in the New Testament? Yes.
How can you prove that? Everything that
was put in the book was everything we
need to come to belief. So let me show
you that verse. Now Jesus did many other
signs in the presence of the disciples
which are not written in this book. But
these are written, so these specific
things are written. Why? So that you may
believe that Jesus is the Christ, the
son of God, and that by believing you
may have life in his name.
So the reason why we don't have the
extra stuff that Jesus did or said is
because the things that are in the book
are necessary for belief and the and
coming to the truth.
So that's why we have what we have. Now,
my question to you is, does Jesus ever
mention Ahmed coming? Does he ever
mention Ahmed before the Quran hops on
the scene? Do we have evidence of that?
Okay, now let me let me ask you a
question. How many Gospels are there?
There's one. It's called the fourfold
Gospel. So do we have do we have a
mention of Ahmed? You don't have You
don't have four Gospels in in your New
Testament?
>> It's all one Gospel. Four accounts, one
Gospel. Do we have a mention of Ahmed?
Wait a minute, don't Are you trying to
evade the question cuz you you just
can't say that.
>> you're evading the question cuz I asked
this like 5 minutes ago and we keep
chopping up on different questions
different questions of and I've Notice
how I've been answering you directly.
Yeah, the questions you asked, I've been
answering them directly.
>> want to You don't want to engage in in
in in some of the questions that I ask.
Like this question, you you're just
you're just you're just going to make
the four Gospels one?
You just can't do that. Okay, we can we
can address that in a second. Are you
going to be able to answer my my
question right now?
>> is part this is part of my answer
because I
What I'm what I'm trying to tell you is
not everything that Jesus said that that
was important. I'm not talking about the
little
minor details. I'm talking about the
things that were important. Not
everything was was was recorded, and we
don't have access to everything
important that he said. Do you believe
that the mention of the next prophet is
important?
Of course. All right, so do we have any
evidence of Jesus mentioning the next
prophet, Ahmed,
before the Quran hops on the scene?
Well, not by the name of Ahmed.
But he does mention he says he's going
to send the the spirit of truth. And
that's some
Muslim scholars have
have uh interpreted that to mean
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him.
What do you think?
I definitely believe it's possible that
could be the understanding or the the
meaning of that of that verse.
>> possibly or it is?
Uh I can't say for sure cuz I don't know
exactly what is authentic from the New
Testament, what's not. Um it's not
really of great importance to to Muslims
because like I said, we have the Quran.
>> It has to be important because it's used
as a proof for the prophethood of
Muhammad and a proof for the truth of
the Quran.
>> Well, the proof of the prophethood of
Muhammad is is simply I mean, does does
prophet does Jesus ever say I'm the last
prophet?
I'm the seal of the prophets. There's
not going to come a prophet after me,
for example? No, so here's the point.
The point is is that
the Quran as an evidence uses the
confirmation of the Torah and the
Gospel.
In chapter 7 verse 157, one of the
proofs for Muhammad's prophethood is
that he is found written in the Torah
and the Gospel, Psalms, and all these
things.
So, this is important for you as a
Muslim and for me as a Christian
to be able to verify this statement. You
know what I'm saying? It's extremely
important.
>> have access to the
to the Torah in in in Hebrew. I don't
think you can read Hebrew, can you? You
Do you have access to the original Torah
uh in the Hebrew
>> I have I have access I have access to
the Hebrew language. Yes, we have
lexicons.
We have access to the Greek.
>> I'm not saying Google Translate. I'm
saying I'm not saying Google Translate.
I said lexicons. Do you have access to
the original Torah? That's That's my
question. Uh so, the Torah that was
written down on Mount Sinai? No. Not not
Not necessarily the
I mean um the the tablet that it was
written on. I'm saying even if it's on
on paper right now, do you have access
to the
>> Okay, yeah. Then yes. Then yes.
Yes.
>> How would you know, though? That's
That's my question. How would you know?
Because we have the Dead Sea Scrolls. We
have the copies of the scrolls that were
preserved that date before even Jesus's
time. We have these things. Thank you,
Joshua. I appreciate you, brother. God
bless you.
>> you can't you weren't there at the time.
Neither was I, of course, but you
you can't you can't verify that nothing
was changed, nothing was
>> can. Because we have because we have the
copies and we can compare. So, the thing
is with our access to what we have, we
know what we have is legitimate because
they all say the same thing. They all
verify one one another and they verify
history as well. And so, with this being
said, we have, for example, we have this
amount of evidence to back up our faith,
right? To verify our faith. And the
Quran uses this as an evidence. We are
supposed to be able to find Muhammad
written in our Torah, written in our
Gospel, find the Psalms talking about
them and things of this nature. Now,
with I'm just I'm addressing the first
claim because
you said in the beginning that we don't
know any we anything that we find out
about Jesus, anything we know about
Jesus comes from the Quran. That's the
only legit source. And then as we
started going down that line and seeing
if that was actually true, we find out
actually no. We don't have anything
about Jesus. We don't know what he
taught. We don't know exactly what he
said. There's no proof of anything that
he said from the Quran.
The Quran will make these claims, but we
can't verify them.
Every time I ask
the the chapter 5
I was
>> Okay. never did. I mean, there's there's
so many verses in the Quran that talk
about Jesus.
Um So, can So, can we
Can we Can we admit Can we acknowledge
that
the statement of Jesus saying that Ahmed
comes after him, that doesn't exist
before the Quran?
No, of course not.
Okay. Because we don't have Like I said,
we don't have the original
uh scriptures. The original
>> Then Then why Then why quote it? Then
why quote Why did you quote John when I
asked you about something like this? And
you you're the one who quoted the
Gospel. You're the one who said, "Well,
you got your Bible open, don't you?"
So, you went to my Bible. I didn't.
I have no problem I have no problem
going to your Bible. It's It's no
problem. But I told you before. Like I
said, we can't say 100% for sure any of
the verses in the New Testament was uh
was accurately
um
quoted from Jesus. And And I And
obviously we cannot be sure about what
the Quran quotes about Jesus. Obviously.
We can't We have no evidence.
>> There's a big difference. The difference
is that
the Quran is revelation from Allah.
Everything is from Allah.
>> Based on what?
Based on what's written in the Quran.
Based on our belief. Got you. So,
because I believe that the Quran is
divinely inspired, therefore the the
Quran is divinely inspired. Okay, fine.
I'll use that same logic.
>> That's what I was asking you about the
prophets, right?
>> I believe I believe the New Testament
Gospel is is divinely inspired and so
therefore it's divinely inspired. We
have what Jesus said. Well, not that
simple. Oh, there's more to it.
>> the New Testament is not because the New
Testament we know we already know for
sure it was written by people. It's So,
who was the Quran written by?
Like I said, the Quran is revelation
from Allah. It's no one
>> Was it written Was it Was it written?
Was it written down on uh a document,
you mean? Yeah. Was it Was the Quran
written?
>> how we have it now.
>> Okay. So, the Quran was written by
people. Here we go.
>> who's the author of the words, though?
The author of the words is Allah. All
right, exactly. So, just like the author
of the Gospel is Jesus, although it was
written by men, we can be sure that it's
divinely inspired because it comes from
Jesus.
>> the wording? Oh, good. Who chose the
wording of the Quran? Allah. So, who
chose the wording of the Gospel? Jesus.
How can you say that when it was written
by four different people? Four different
authors.
>> How can you say that the that Allah is
the one who decided the wording of the
Quran when it was written by different
authors?
It was Okay, if I Let me
>> Let me explain something to you. I'mma
use your same criteria.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm going to explain. The
Gospels, they were not uh Jesus didn't
say He didn't dictate those those words
to to those authors.
And they wrote it down word for word.
What is your What is your What is your
evidence of that?
Because uh for example, you'll find
um It says Jesus It says Jesus It says
Jesus said this and then they quote what
Jesus said. So, how is that a not a
quote of Jesus?
>> is who?
Was it Was it a
>> What do you mean, who? Was it an
eyewitness? You said You said in your
example, it doesn't matter who you
dictated it to as long as they dictate
the words directly from you.
>> has to be present. That's the author's
>> words. No, you didn't say that. You
didn't say that.
>> That's just my point.
He has to be present. Okay. So, we have
All right. So, we have the people
present here. So, were the people
present during Muhammad's time when they
dictated what Muhammad was reciting?
So,
the prophet Muhammad, he got revelation
from Allah. He recited it. His
companions wrote down word for word. How
do you know? Now,
well, if you don't want to I can't make
you believe that, but this is how
>> I'm just asking, how do you know? This
is what history says. You can
You can make a claim
and then I ask you, how do you know? You
have to provide the evidence for your
claim. I'm just saying this is what
history says.
>> What What What history? What history?
The biography of the prophet, peace be
upon him. The biography of the prophet.
Where do we Where do I find that? Where
do I find that?
Uh there's many books on the the
biography
You talking about by Ibn Ishaq?
Uh that's one of them. Okay. So, Ibn
Ishaq says that the Gospel of John was
written by John and it's one of the
Gospels of Jesus. So.